[موسيقى]
قد لا تكون هناك حاجه لاجراء احصاءات
جديده لتبيان ارتفاع نسبه العزوبيه في
لبنان فهذه النسبه كانت الاعلى عربيا قبل
اعوام ولم تختفي باي حال اضرب هو العوامل
المسببه لها
[موسيقى]
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تقطع الطريق على
الشباب اللبناني امام تاسيسي حياه زوجيه
وعائليه وتدفع بهم الى الهجره تاتي في
مقدمه هذه العوامل فضلا عن تكاليف عقود
الزواج ماذا فعل عام الماضي بمجموعه فتيات
الى اطلاق حمله وهشتاج تزوجني بدون مهر
والتاخر في سن الزواج مرضه لرغبه الشباب
ولسه من النساء بتحقيق الذاتي
والاستقلاليه والامساك بزمام حياتهم اذ لم
يعد مفهوم السعاده بالمقاييس الحديثه
مرتبطه حكما بتاسيس عائله وبانجاب الاولاد
على ان الراغبات بالخيار الاخير بامكانهن
اللجوء الى عمليات تجميد البويضات التي
اصبحت رائجه للحفاظ على قدرتهم على الحمل
مستقبلا
عم تشتغل وعم تصرف على اهله رجالي قاعد
بالبيت يعني ما بقى حدا يقول لحدا عانس
يعني
العصر الحجري يعني كلمه عانس لا يجوز انه
تنقال بهذه الايام
نحنا بالقرن الواحد و20 المراه فيها تعمل
اكثر من الرجال يعني
عانس انه هذا من النهايه كله نصيب يعني بس
انه كلمه هي كلمه مؤذيه وبالاخص للمراه
اكثر من الرجال
ونسبه العزوبيه او تاخر سنه الزواج او
كلاهما يفرضان تراجعا في نسبه الولاده
الامر الذي سيضع المجتمع اللبناني وفي مدى
قصير في خانه المجتمعات الهريمه لصباح
العربيه رينادويه بيروت